is this the reason why the taliban's at
the theme park because there's someone
else antagonizing us now yeah they got
they got time
dude like in Echo Park the television
Echo Park I'm the duck
[Music]
everybody know about Putin yeah he's my
best friend he's battling cancer and
Parkinson's disease apparently whoa
emails have claimed did the lady smell
him
Russian President Vladimir Putin is
battling both pancreatic cancer and
Parkinson's disease according to a new
report citing leaked Kremlin emails a
Russian intelligence Source appeared to
confirm in messages viewed by XYZ what
has long been rumored about the 70 year
old strong man quote I can confirm he
has been diagnosed with early stage
Parkinson's disease but it's already
progressing the security services
Insider reportedly claimed this fact
will be denied in every possible way and
hidden The Source said Putin is
regularly stuffed with all kinds of
heavy steroids and Innovative pain
killing injections to stop the spread of
pancreatic cancer he was recently
diagnosed with whoa it not only causes a
lot of pain Putin has a state of
puffiness of the face and other side
effects including steroids yeah are we
feeling empathy for this no do you think
that's why he went into war because of
the [ __ ] steroid rage and all the
crazy [ __ ] yeah
it's head and [ __ ] I heard we made him
go into war
weed
we're like
we've been at peace because I think it
was our our whole Arrangement is if we
keep NATO this far away from him then
everyone's gonna be cool and then I
think uh Biden or whatever convinced
NATO troops to advance so they're like
if you are gonna do that then I'm gonna
invade Ukraine I know I know um
that was uh highly accurate oh [ __ ] so I
actually think we we actually instigated
it yeah we instigated it but then we go
oh this guy wants War when we are the
ones the way that we really did
instigate it and it and it wasn't just
bited but like it it goes back before
even Obama yeah is
so when the uh Russia was USSR there was
all the Eastern Bloc countries Eastern
Europe they were under USSR right and
then Germany was split into two and then
that's when the whole Cold War [ __ ]
happened and then there was the whole
Missile Crisis and all that right and
afterwards there were like hey maybe
it's not a good idea yeah that's right
let's just like chill and then and then
um that's also when the USSR turned into
Russia and they're no longer Communists
the Soviet Union disbanded remember that
in all those countries the Eastern Bloc
countries they became
um no longer a part of the USSR like
Romania and all these other countries
and then the U.S started in the NATO
group started recruiting all of those
countries into the group because that's
also a good way for them to make money
it's like a franchise the US military
hey I could throw my bases there I could
give you protection
from what I don't know but the
protection is from Russia right and then
it's like we'll send you money we'll
send you guns we'll send you whatever
foreign but then these countries if they
are now part of NATO they got to pay up
so it's a military franchise it's like
owning McDonald's it's like hey I have
my U.S bases in Romania I have my U.S
bases in Poland or whatever I just keep
helping and helping and helping but you
have to buy our tanks you have to buy
our like equipment you have to buy our
[ __ ] and then it just keeps going and
now now they're like we want to put more
missiles why do you need missiles and
then it gets closer and closer to Russia
and then Russia is like what the [ __ ]
now you're like putting up missiles
right next to my country right so you're
arming yourselves to take us down which
feels more Cold War animosity
but I mean regardless of fact
they're in War I think what might be
interesting is for us to figure out what
do we think would happen in this
instance if Putin really does have
pancreatic cancer and he passes away or
something yeah and he passes away or
something like that what do we think is
going to happen does he have a second
dude under him that's going to do
exactly what he wants I have never heard
of second in command that like is so so
like ready to take of the way we hear
about like North Korean dictatorship and
like lineage I don't know about that for
Russia so unless somebody has heard of a
specific second in command there was a
president a puppet president that they
had
so there was like a couple years ago uh
democratically elected Russian president
but he was basically under the control
Putin and then miraculously the next
election Putin won
so it is the same party same thing like
I mean like yeah so that's what I'm
saying though like what would happen if
like Putin died but they're probably
thinking about that it's not like it's
something you know that like he passed
away randomly and they're like oh who's
second best if he knows he's diagnosed
with these things they're probably
coming up with some sort of plan you
know he's gonna take action on it yeah
it's the second in command how does he
have the same Mission as Putin
especially in Wartime right like and the
conviction and the grit to like follow
through with it too especially if you
got the rest of the world that's already
right like unless it's North Korea yeah
does it stop the world North Korea it's
like that Kingdom yeah they're like the
king like they're like a kingdom like
they're like my grandpa and then my dad
and then or like it just keeps going
down like that and there's a succession
plan even like so in Cuba's something
recently with with Castro like not
really you know there it's like what's
gonna happen then there's it's quiet
same with Venezuela after Chavez is out
it's like okay so Maduro I think he's
the new guy but there's chaos there
they're just like out so like what's
gonna happen with Putin if there's no
one that's charismatic and that's
powerful enough to take over because
they could just have infighting yeah
they could be yeah yeah there's no one
really that's gonna be able to take his
seat
because he the dictator issue is that
you're the charismatic leader and then
there's no one there to like replace
your seat unless you have a Heir yeah
pancreatic cancer is crazy too because
what does it do well pancreas creates
your insulin so if he has that I'm sure
he's taking insulin shots too so is it
like a diabetes he just has all kinds of
[ __ ] he has to take throw that in with
Parkinson's disease at the same time in
memory that's a crazy yeah it sounds
like
they're making the decisions for the
rest of us yeah and they're it's like
old old men make decisions and young
guys die for it you know Martin's not
making decisions we just make Michael
Phelps the [ __ ] president that guy
you only want a couple Olympics Michael
Phelps knows the champion dude he knows
how to navigate the waters you know he
just swims to Russia if there's a
problem who's the buffest President we
ever had the barnold is the closest
president or like political leader I
guess buff is a strong word for
everybody Obama looked like he was good
at basketball yeah he was balling dude
that's racist and he's gonna he's gonna
paddle board he's athletic I think it's
uh Teddy Roosevelt well he's not like oh
yeah oh he was a gangster though right
yeah wasn't there a president like a
famous president that got stuck in the
bathtub because he was a little
overweight
sound like a Grover Cleveland [ __ ]
that's such a Grover Cleveland thing to
do so at this at this time is Ukraine
still under attack from Russia like at
the same ferocity that it was when it
was first reported or what the [ __ ] or
did it just die now like is the news
dying faster than the attack is or
what's what's the deal I think there's
there was a I saw a video the other day
of a of a fighter jet crashing into a I
saw that too yeah but that was a Russian
jet crashing into a Russian building oh
it was I thought it was Ukraine I guess
I got malfunctioned its own [ __ ] [ __ ]
or something and also you know for all
we know this whole idea Putin battling
pancreatican that could also be
propaganda yeah like he's weak you can't
trust nothing calling ourselves out on
the news source over here like make them
make them think we're weak so we can get
away with some [ __ ] post the link maybe
because we seem weak with like Biden
being sick and tired and old and then so
like maybe they have to make their
president like a baby switch wouldn't
that be funny if Biden was faking it the
whole time to get people to like think
he was incompetent and then right yeah
he's like yeah and he starts like just
dunking on people in the election he's
just at home [ __ ] going ham on a
Peloton he starts reciting things
perfectly with no gas his suits are cut
offs now and he has [ __ ] massive
biceps damn
yeah yeah yeah it's like a whole tactic
to get other countries confident and
[ __ ] but then smash him at the end I do
find it even more potential and
interesting the idea of spreading that
type of propaganda that oh this is the
point in the strategy where we start
letting the you know the Western
countries and Nations think that we're
weakening let's throw out some sort of
thing that's like much of way more of a
curveball because maybe the commentators
have been saying that he's getting
puffiness like let's let's call it
steroids and but you know what I'm
saying that could be sadistically it
could be yeah it could be because
Warfare exists on all levels and that's
super effective but there's so much
[ __ ] curveball [ __ ] like the pipeline
exploding how they're like oh Putin did
that what's what what's the what's the
pipeline explosion it's like a natural
gas pipeline that supplies through
Russia and then apparently it blew up
but then they're saying that us blew it
up the UK they're saying that the UK
blew it up and as soon as it was
everyone's 10 credits executed the Prime
Minister the lady who resigned as soon
as it blew up she texted somebody and
said it's done
and then in the UK in the UK the the
female prime minister who resigned out
of nowhere huh is this the reason why
the taliban's at the theme park because
there's someone else antagonizing us now
yeah yeah they got they got time dude
anything they got paid they got paid
time off we're having a blast let's go
let's go [ __ ] bike in Echo Park the
television Echo Park I'm the duck I mean
arguably would you be kind of interested
at a Taliban Yelp where they reviewed
certain things and you got to see what
they thought of it that would be
hilarious now that they get to like kind
of kick back a little bit you know yeah
just in the next decade instead of the
Kardashians this is the Taliban they
have no reality show on E they're all
they're all going into county fairs and
shooting up the fun house mirrors
executive produced by Sasha Baron Cohen
dude yeah just think about it just kind
of writing itself as we speak that is
[ __ ] wild I don't know I think we
live in a really crazy time too because
before you were just told one narrative
and you believed it but now there's just
so many so many different pieces of
information and you're from like just
people that are vloggers that are on
location like recording [ __ ] but also
you have like independent journalists
you have you know Legacy Media you have
good old JK news and then you're just
like what the [ __ ] like I'm so confused
there's so many different angles here
and for what reason I'm also curious
about curious about like motive like why
are they telling me this info like are
they telling me this so our perception
about Russia is this way or like are
they trying to manipulate the US like
citizens to say hey we don't want this
war so then we back that we back off of
Ukraine so then Russia can just go in or
like what's really going on I don't know
I think the hardest part is that there's
a move to be made in some sector for
every decision that takes place in the
world so let's say that there's an
invasion of Russia somebody knows that
oh if there's an invasion brush I'm
going to capitalize on it and do this
thing so then everybody looks at that
thing when they discover it and go
that's the reason this happened but it's
not the reason it happened someone just
took advantage of it just like covid
like when covet happened all these
people took advantage of that knowing
but way before that [ __ ] even was close
to being a thing they knew they would do
that if a lockdown happened so
everyone's monetizing off the moment but
then people see the thing and they go
Cove it's all fake it was just for this
guy to make money like nah dude it was
real but you know this is the effects
afterwards that's just everybody has a
move right that's the thing like toilet
paper companies dude his friends own a
own a factory in Vietnam and he was
saying like when kovid was happening in
China that factory just turned into a
mask making factory and they just
started cranking out masks and then
that's the movement and then when covet
hit lockdown hit they were just selling
a ton of masks and I was like oh I can
see how conspiracies start because
they're they're just like hey these guys
were smart enough to think ahead yeah
and then understand like where things
are going so then because they saw what
happened with SARS they saw like all the
bird like bird flu [ __ ] whatever and
they're like oh there was a they didn't
have enough masks back then so they're
like now this time we're not gonna be
late exactly yeah yeah and then so but
when you can when you see that you can
be like Oh The Mask industry they're the
ones that [ __ ] make covid so like
they can start selling masks and [ __ ]
it's like The Big Short like the guy who
monetized off the housing bubble didn't
cause the housing bubbles he's simply
just took advantage of the situation he
saw the market that when it happened
they would do nothing in regulations to
prevent it next time so he's like you
can do this every [ __ ] time man and
he's predicting some major Fallout soon
too really what's the prediction name is
like Michael Murray uh or Christian Bale
what is he saying yeah what's he saying
off camera tell us off camera so we can
capitalize you want to make some real
bucks
it's not from a mastermind economic
meltdown I mean what for one thing he
didn't get rid of all of his crypto he
got rid of almost all of his assets
except for the jail industry oh [ __ ] by
big on jails guys yeah he it's probably
because the jail system's gonna
go up Pump yeah so jail companies that's
a crazy thing to bet on yeah for real
isn't it that's like you have some heavy
inside knowledge if you're like oh jail
is going to be or just the way you're
you're yeah the way your mind works
you're like 16 steps ahead you're like
okay once the recession goes and people
start being delinquents and then people
start getting losing their jobs so
everybody's gonna get arrested and they
just tried to like abolish like you know
the funding police so every jail sector
invest now you know
that was a big criticism on his part
when he was betting against the housing
market people were calling him
unpatriotic because he was betting
against America yeah so it's like dude
if you can think like that where you're
not held back by any form of like oh I
have allegiance to this country you're
gonna make a lot of money man during
covet um Warren Buffett dumped a lot of
his cash into
um grocery stores wow like Kroger and
all that stuff and then yeah with the
inflating prices and all that like look
at it he's not wrong let's just do what
Warren Buffett does all right no let's
do a Pelosi's husband does Pelosi's
husband moves get attacked by a guy with
a hand which he did get attacked yeah
[Music]
[Music]